bienvenue en irlande
il était une fois deux fermes voisines
la ferme mais bodhum rosemary vyver est
au bout du chemin il y avait ma ferme
mon fils anthony poser ces questions
solitaire aux étoiles pourquoi m'as-tu
fait ainsi
rose-marie monde donne
était éperdument amoureuse il ya ces
champs verdoyants sur cette terre
viennent un peu importe que c'est ça me
retient ici
quand il dit des choses comme ça là
mais pas dans patiemment moque tu
ressembles à john kerry il était aussi
timbre et la pleine lune s'est noyé
volontairement enlevé tomber la belle
roche attachée autour du cou
rose-marie on se connaît depuis assez
longtemps maintenant voudrais tu
m'épouser
accus signé les papiers pour que la
ferme soit cédé à anthony voit pas de
lien direct entre quoi et quoi entre moi
et toi
mon cousin respire tôt la plus belle
voiture une mamie tu as laissé la ferme
à une américaine datant d après lui vous
vous attendez après quoi moi j'attends
pas j'ai fox aime ça
tu devrais venir à new york un jour
anthony ne se mariera jamais s'il faut
attendre encore je considère mse
faudrait tu te fasses conjuguée au
complet ce site à l'intention d'attendre
après lui
belliot kaunas comme déjà eu un rêve que
tu poursuivait depuis en france et que
tu n'arrivais pas à abandonner tu as mis
cette barrière entre nous on reste été
rendue heureuse ou malheureuse
tu a embrassé adam c'est lui qui m'a
embrassé c'est pour ça qu'il revient
j'ai du mal à comprendre les gens d'ici
pour rand est aussi compliqué vous
accepter des choses insensées je n'aime
pas me disputer qui aiment ça la moitié
des landes mais pas moi toujours
est il qu'on a wish we will find me peu
je t'en veux
confirmer que l'amour
attention et après tu te trouvais
durant combien de jours verrons-nous
encore le soleil brille et ne brille pas
il brise moi oui lieu qu'on
ainsi qu'aux
[Musique]